Hello everyone and welcome to Unity to Unreal.
This is a course designed for Unreal Engine 5.6 about
transitioning your workflow from Unity to Unreal Engine.
This course is being brought to you today by myself,
Alex Coulom, as well as Wit Sellers.
We are Unreal Engine authorized instructor partners,
and look forward to teaching you the ins and
outs of going from Unity to Unreal.
So what are we going to be covering today?
First, we're going to get our bearings.
We're going to do an overview of
basic concepts inside of Unity and Unreal.
And we're also going to create some basic assets
and compare those side by side between the two programs.
Next, we're going to work on adding new content
into Unreal, as well as migrating an existing scene
from Unity into our Unreal Engine project,
and look at what kind of assets can come over
and which ones we're going to need to rebuild.
So once we know that,
then we're going to be bringing back
interactivity to our project.
We're going to look at Unreal Engine's gameplay framework.
We're going to rebuild materials,
reincorporate our animations into our characters,
create a new character asset,
as well as script custom logic
using Blueprints visual scripting inside of Unreal.
Then we're going to go into leveraging
some of the tools the engine has to offer,
like lighting with Lumen,
and affecting exposure and bloom with post-processing.
We'll look at modeling tools
or editing some of our assets that we have imported.
And then we're going to start working with audio
and package our game
so that other people can play what we've created.
All right, so here we're looking at a comparison
of our scene in Unity and what it will look like
after we've brought it over into Unreal.
We have an NPC character that's dancing
and the player will be able to switch
what dance they're doing
with the press of a button on their keyboard.
This dancer is surrounded by glowing columns
that have an animated material
and the color of the columns can change
when the player presses a button
on their keyboard as well.
And then in Unreal, we've added in a new character
as well as changed up the environment
and illumination settings to give it a more vibey look.
Okay, so let's take a look
and see what this is actually going to look like in engine.
So here's our scene in Unity.
There we go, lovely.
We have an extra package that we're using here
that gives us a free flying camera
to mimic the player pawn that comes by default
inside of Unreal.
We'll see that when we press space,
our color of our cubes change
and the dance that our character is performing
also changes up.
If we press space again, color changes back
and the dance will also go back to our original.
Fantastic.
Now, inside of Unreal,
we're gonna see something that looks very similar
except we've added a few more assets
that we'll cover over the rest of the class.
We've also added in a new character.
We've got some music playing,
but when we press space,
our dance changes and our colors change
and all of this is a real time lighting.
Okay, so now let's look
and see how we can take the default Unreal Engine layout
and put it into this layout
that more closely resembles the Unity editor layout
you might be used to.
So we'll open Unreal here.
First thing I'm gonna do is open the content drawer,
which is like our project folder.
I'm gonna dock this in the layout here
under the viewport.
Then I'm gonna drag this outliner panel over here
to the left of the viewport.
And now we have something
that looks maybe a little bit more familiar.
And then again,
we have our main menu toolbar up here at the top,
our play and editor tools right here over the viewport.
The details is gonna be like our inspector panel,
outliner is like our scene hierarchy,
and then the content browser is like our project folder.
And then finally, if you don't see your console,
the output log, which is Unreal's version,
can be found down here underneath your content browser.
On this slide, we're looking a little bit
at the Unreal asset hierarchy
and how different assets nest into each other.
For example, you might have a world
that contains different levels or sub-levels,
or in a world partition sense,
you might have a lot of different streaming assets in there
and then within those, you'll have individual actors.
And then each actor can have various components
or blueprints that can get more and more detailed.
And then of course, from there, you can go down further
and look at nodes or even code.
But this just gives you a brief overview
about the relationship to each other.
There's more detail about each of these
in the description here,
as well as in the Unreal Engine documentation.
So now we're gonna jump a little bit deeper
into our program comparison
and look at Unity's scene hierarchy
versus Unreal's level outliner.
In Unity, the main way that I have found
to keep my hierarchy organized
is to use empty game objects as parents
in order to group things together.
And Unreal, we can still do that with empty actors,
but we also have the ability to group things into folders.
These folders don't actually appear in the level itself,
they're only there in the outliner.
And so they're a way that you can keep things
grouped together without needing to physically tie
or virtually tie all of their transforms together
under a parent object.
Additionally, the button to add a new engine supplied actor
is moved from the hierarchy window
to the toolbar in Unreal or the main menu toolbar.
And also there is a separate levels window.
So in Unity, if you have multiple scenes open
at the same time, they'll all appear in the hierarchy.
Whereas in Unreal Engine,
you'll see all of the actors together in the outliner,
but if you wanna see the different levels,
assets themselves, that'll be in a separate levels window
that you'll open and can dock next to the outliner.
Okay, so now we're gonna look at the inspector panel
versus the detail panel.
You'll see they look pretty similar.
We have our various components laid out vertically,
but one sort of key difference to note here
is that we don't have a checkbox next to the name
of the cube in Unreal like we do in Unity.
So if you want to disable an actor
in the similar kind of way that you would in Unity,
you need to go into the rendering section
of that actor detail panel and search for hidden in game
so it doesn't show up when you're playing it
in play mode or disable the checkbox for visible
if you don't wanna see it when you're working in editor.
So now we're gonna go a little bit deeper again
on prefabs versus blueprints.
Here we're looking at the Unity prefab editor.
This looks very similar to the default editor layout
for a scene.
We have a hierarchy that can contain sub prefabs
or game objects, each with their own components,
but all logic needs to be added to prefabs
via C sharp script components within their sub game objects
and all of those components need to create links
to one another within itself
or you manually have to link them together.
Over in the Unreal Engine side,
we have a viewport that is similar
to what we have in Unity, including the components window,
which has a little mini outliner,
not unlike what we get with the world outliner
in the Unreal Engine level.
And here you'll typically have a collection of assets
like static meshes, lights, actors of that nature,
though you can also have child blueprints in here
nested and containing all the complexities
of that linked blueprint.
However, we certainly advise caution when doing that
as it can very quickly make the parent blueprint
more complicated and harder to work with.
In the next video, we'll look at how to create
basic assets in Unreal Engine
and compare them to their Unity equivalents.